BACK TO YOU.
>> Ed: NICE TO SEE WINSTON THE
PUG ON THE MEND.
JONATHAN SERRIE COVERING UP FOR
US.
>> Sandra: IN AN ABRUPT
REVERSAL, LAWMAKERS ARE SAYING
THEY WILL NOT RETURN TO
WASHINGTON NEXT WEEK.
THAT LEAVES THE STATUS OF
WORKING AMERICANS ECONOMICALLY
UP IN THE AIR.
>> WE HAD NO CHOICE.
THE CAPITAL PHYSICIAN RECOMMENDS
THAT WE NOT COME BACK, THEN WE
HAVE TO TAKE THAT GUIDANCE IN
THE INTEREST OF THE SAFETY OF
THE PEOPLE WHO WORK HERE AND THE
CUSTODIANS IN THE BUILDING,
THOSE WHO HAVE TO BE HERE.
>> Sandra: LET’S BRING AN OHIO
CONGRESSMAN AND RANKING MEMBER
OF THE HOUSE OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE, JIM JORDAN.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
SO DO YOU AGREE WITH THAT
DECISION?
WHAT KIND OF ALL REMEMBER THE
IMAGE LAST WEEK OF YOU SHOWING
UP FOR THE SEAM IS ABOUT STIMULU
NO MASK.
DO YOU THINK THE THREAT WAS
ENOUGH TO KEEP MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS FREE FROM RETURNING TO
WASHINGTON?
>> STATES ARE REOPENING, WHY
WOULDN’T CONGRESS?
HEALTH CARE WORKERS HAVE NEVER
STOPPED.
WE’VE BEEN WORKING EVERY SINGLE
DAY’S OUT CRISIS BUT SOMEHOW
U.S. CONGRESS CAN’T COME BACK TO
WORK.
THERE’S TASK FORCE MEETINGS ALL
OVER THE COUNTRY BUT THE
TASK FORCE THAT IS SUPPOSED TO
MEET AND DEAL WITH THE BIG
ISSUES, LET’S GET BACK IN
SESSION.
YOU ARE DESCRIBING IT, WE CAN DO
IT.
I DON’T KNOW WHY YOU’RE NOT BACK
DOING THE WORK OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, IT SEEMS LIKE THAT’S
EXACTLY WHERE WE SHOULD BE BUT
UNFORTUNATELY NANCY PELOSI WILL
NOT CALL US BACK.
>> Sandra: WE WILL TAKE THAT
AS YOU DO NOT AGREE WITH THAT.
THIS FOURTH ROUND OF STIMULUS,
THIS IS LARGELY BEING DEBATED
NOW.
QUESTIONS OVER WHETHER OR NOT
THERE WILL BE A BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT FOR ANOTHER REEF
PACKAGE, WHERE DO YOU STAND?
>> THE BEST STIMULUS IS TO GO
BACK TO WORK.
THE BEST PHASE FOR IS TO GO BACK
TO WORK AND WE ARE SEEING STATES
DO THAT.
WE’VE ALREADY SPENT $3 TRILLION
AND THAT WAS NECESSARY BECAUSE
WHEN THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
STATE GOVERNMENTS TO HELP
BUSINESS OWNERS YOU CAN’T ENGAGE
IN YOUR LIKELIHOOD AND YOU CAN’T
RUN YOUR BUSINESS, YOU HAVE TO
HELP SMALL BUSINESSES AND YOU
HAVE TO HELP SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS.
THE BEST APPROACH NOW IS LET’S
SIMPLY GO BACK TO WORK.
OUR STATES ARE BEGINNING TO DO
THAT, LET’S DO THAT AS QUICKLY
AS POSSIBLE.
THAT’S THE BEST STIMULUS, THAT’S
THE BEST PHASE FOUR, GO BACK TO